this protest in Seattle Washington on
June 1st looks to be contained but in a
split second everything unravels since
the killing of George Floyd police
departments across the country are
facing increased scrutiny over their
tactics this incident in Seattle's
Capitol Hill neighborhood is under
investigation by the police departments
internal watchdog group for the use of
pepper spray blast balls and tear gas to
disperse a crowd The Wall Street Journal
analyzed over two hours of footage shot
by multiple witnesses as well as police
scanner audio from the scene to examine
how police and protesters tactics pushed
the incident into chaos an hour after a
citywide curfew about 2,000 people are
headed east on Pine Street toward the
Seattle police East precinct to protest
[Applause]
but Seattle PD quickly erected a barrier
one block away the scene still seems
under control the precinct captain even
listens and responds to protest our
demands the tone changes when an
organizer warns that some people have
other tactics in mind
this boy
Wow overloaded control then a crucial
change in police tactics they swapped
the line of bike officers for officers
in riot gear they also discussed using
pepper spray what they refer to as OSE
short for oleoresin capsicum then a
change in tactics from some protesters a
few at the front begin raising umbrellas
which protesters frequently used to
shield themselves from pepper spray and
tear gas police experts we spoke with
note that umbrellas are often seen as a
hazard because they block sight lines
then the pivotal moment a person in
front is holding an umbrella that
extends to past the barricade an officer
reaches out attempting to push it out of
the way the officer grabs the umbrella
and the person tries to hold on at the
same time another officer deploys pepper
spray at the direction of the incident
commander or I see other officers follow
suit spraying as the crowd backs away
some in the crowd they're objects toward
the police line then the order to deploy
blasts falls in CS or tear gas
[Music]
most of the protesters have dispersed at
this point but if you remain close to
the barrier despite to your guts filling
the air Seattle Police Department policy
dictates that once a crowd poses an
imminent risk to public safety or
property destruction police should give
in order to disperse the policy also
states officers will not use blast balls
until a dispersal order has been issued
footage we reviewed didn't show officers
giving a verbal order the Seattle Police
Department said the incident is still
under investigation police declare the
June 1st protest a riot because some
people in the crowd threw objects at
police 11 people were arrested according
to seattle police 12 people required
medical attention including police and
members of the public